اعصار جديد تترقبه سواحل العمانيه وبحر
العرب وسط تحذيرات مشدده حيث اوضحت
الارصاد الجويه العمانيه ان الاعصار يبعد
الان عن سواحل السلطنه 1020 كيلو متر
وحذرت السلطات في عمان من ارتفاع امواج
البحر الى سته امتار بدءا من اليوم حتى
الاثنين المقبل من جهه اعلنا المركز
الوطني للارصاد السعودي ان الحاله
المداريه في بحر العرب لا يوجد لها اي
تاثير مباشر على الاجواب في المملكه
العربيه السعوديه
من مسقط ينضم الينا اخصائي الارصاد الجويه
بالطيران المدني محمد المدحاني سيد محمد
مرحبا بك معي في نشره الرابعه ما الذي
يمكن ان نعرفه اولا عن هذا الاعصار بيبر
جوي ما هو هذا الاعصار وهل وصل فعلا الى
عمان في هذه اللحظات
مرحبا بكم وبالمستمعين الكرام طبعا هنا من
المركز الوطني للاداره المبكر ولا من
المخاطر المتعدده في سلطنه عمان تم اصدار
تقرير رقم ثلاثه باخر التحديثات للحاله
المداريه حيث تشير اخر صور الاقمار
الاصطناعيه الى كمركز الاعصار المداري من
الدرجه الاولى وسط بحر العرب الموقع
الحالي هو على خط طول
66.4 شرقا ودائره عرض
14.8 شمالا وتوفل سرعه الرياح حول المركز
حوالي 64 الى 70 عقده ويبعد مركز الاعصار
عن عن سواحل سلطنه عمان حوالي 1020 كيلو
متر ويتحرك باتجاه الشمال بسرعه تبلغ
من خمسه الى سبعه كيلو متر في الساعه
وتبعد اقرب كتله سحب ماطره حوالي 630 كلم
ولا يزال اعصار مداري من الدرجه الاولى
متى من المتوقع ان يصل الى عمان اذا او
تتاثر به الاجواء العمانيه
مباشره على سواحل السلطنه خلال ثلاثه
الايام القادمه كما تشير ايضا النماذج
العدديه الى احتماليه ضئيله باتجاه الحاله
المداريه الى سواحل السلطنه هل سبق وان
ضربت هذه الحاله المداريه او مرت بعمان
خلال السنوات الماضيه
خلال سنه الماضيه هناك عده حالات غير هذه
الحاله حاله
هي حاله تحدث يعني هذا الاعصار المداري
اطلق عليه لانه تكون في بحر العرب هذه
الفتره هناك عده اعاصير اخرى حدثت نعم
اثرت على سواحل السلطان طيب
تاثيراتها كم ستستمر او هل هناك مثلا يعني
تاثيرات سباقيه متوقعه من قبلكم في
الارصاد الجويه
حاليا
هناك تاثيرات غير مباشره وهي تدفق السحب
العاليه على سواحل المطله لبحر العرب كذلك
حاله البحر قد يكون البحر سوف يكون البحر
هائج الموت على سواحل بحر بحر العرب
المطله على سواحل الامانيه المطله على بحر
العرب قد يرتفع الموج الى من ثلاثه الى
خمسه امتار من مسائل اليوم الجمعه
خلال ثلاثه ايام القادمه طيب ارتفاع موجه
بحري الى سته امتار يعني ليس من خطوره هذا
الامر اليوم الاحد اليس خطيرا هذا الامر
على السواحل العمانيه
نعم كذلك بهذا السبب ندع المواطنين
المواطنين والمقيمين الى اخذ الحيطه
والحذر وعدم ارتياد البحر خلال ثلاثه ايام
القادمه وعلى اخذ المعلومات من المصادر
الصحيحه اشكرك جزيل الشكر من مسقط اخصائي
الارصاد الجويه بالطيران المدني محمد
المدحاني شكرا لك
لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب
الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس
التنبيهات